good morning Hank it's Friday February
23rd these are my books there are many
like them but these are mine first we
have this bookshelf which I've had since
college then we have this bookshelf
which we acquired this summer this
bookshelf is actually being held up by
books we've had this bookshelf for a few
years then we have these bookshelves
which I got as a present from my
mother-in-law a couple years ago and
then of course we have this bookshelf
which is where I film most days and we
have this which is like your magical
floating bookshelf only slightly
different if you take one away it
continues to float so Hank that's where
I keep my books around the house we
don't have lots of stacks of books and
random places because whenever we need a
bookshelf we just buy a new one
bookshelves are like $20 I mean you can
buy a bookshelf for less than it costs
to take your wife to see the Eddie
Murphy movie Norbit I mean a bookshelf
is cheaper than Norbit so buy more
bookshelves put them down there by the
map of Narnia it is very hard for me
however to get rid of books and to
moderate the number of books that I have
I mean some of these books let's face it
I'm never going to read again consider
for example the day nobody shared in
your pants another example is Devon
DeWeese is 638 page nonfiction book
Islamization and native religion in the
golden horde in my career as a why
novelist it is rare that I am asked by
someone how is it that the uzbek people
came to be Muslims Hank to answer your
questions about ebooks and libraries and
used bookstores I decided to bring in
another author Maureen Johnson the
author of four almost five books what
you think about used bookstores I like
them in to you no problem the fact
they're taking your money
oh no no not at all what are barbers I
love libraries I won't mind can't not be
Pro library is this actually a debate
well it's more of an agreement it seems
like but a lot of people would think
that authors might get angry about the
fact that you don't get money from every
time someone checks your book out of the
library
trouble with my readers is that they
don't get money because I put a $20 bill
in the copy of all my books and so the
first person who reads it gets the 20
how he was supposed to afford to buy
everything they want to read so in the
general agreement seems to be the
writers at least the extremely
scientific sample with me and Maureen
Johnson are pretty much in favor of used
bookstores and in favor of libraries I
think most of us would rather have an
audience than countless riches if we
wanted to be rich we'd be doing
something else like blogging about
environmental technology Maureen Johnson
just had a fantastic invention idea the
ebook for the weed I want to go to page
39 now Josh yeah and now in parting I am
going to read a book with my we by the
power of the we I compel this page to
turn turn them yes hey I'll see you on
Monday they throw a sharing party